ça fait 12 ans que tu passes ça fait
deux ans que tu échoues jamais tout ce
sont donc ceux des globules blancs et
ils sont bien propres homogène et le
cholestérol et le menton flèche
bon vient d'arriver au festival électro
maroco ce soir
vous avez dormi 18 heures
j'ai pu diagnostiquer une fracture du
coccyx dans votre état vous ne pouvez
pas prendre l'avion abdelkader vous
apportera assistance à domicile à 424
matin mais dix minutes chocolat en fait
c'est du placebo ce que tu leur donnes
noms qui étaient
taxés leur dis bah y'a des heures pour
le vin si l'odeur qu'ils dealer du pain
c'est pas ça
dorénavant vous êtes en état
d'arrestation
ils veulent pas me remet mon passeport
je peux même pas quitter le maroc
pourrait pas mettre en boîte
électronique causé trop de napa excuses
je peux rester avec lui on par exemple
vous êtes ici chez vous c'est ça le spi
qualité marocaine
c'est pas d'avis pourquoi tu a sauté
alors je suis obligé
[Rires]
la musique arabe mais d'une hausse de
vie
autant regarder strap expliqué l'ars
hopla avait comme il sera bon
[Musique]